one time I got a phone call and it was
this guy that was just like hey I'm your
son and I was like no [ __ ] way
[Music]
and welcome back to a special edition
PG-13 version of the careful boys today
we have dancing can sitting in the seat
dancing can there it is right now I
gotta show my moves off wow and uh Ryan
take it away okay all right I was asking
these fine gentlemen and Lady before the
cameras turned on how did you ask your
first girlfriend to be your girlfriend
or boyfriend can uh me first okay geez
wow you're a good mediator man yeah
yeah you guys work well as a team uh in
middle school I was in eighth grade I
had just moved from Gardena to where was
it Garden Grove oh Vietnam to Vietnam
okay good yeah so I I went to middle
school and it was my first time going to
school with a bunch of Asian people
because normally I came from a school of
predominantly black and Mexican and then
I was like wow there's so many Asian
people here and then I I would see the
Asian girls I'm like wow so this is what
it's like to see like yep boom and then
to see my sister in a sexual way I
didn't really know anything about dating
or anything but I did know that I liked
uh Asian girls because I was like man
they're so cute I've never seen them
before you know so I would uh hang out
with my friends and then some of my
friends would be like hey uh so-and-so
likes you you want to ask them out I'm
like sure did you know what that meant
when someone says ask them no I didn't
but I was like yeah she looks cute you
know sure why not and then uh after
school she came over to me and we're
like hey you know do you like me I'm
like yeah and I was like okay let's uh
get together I'm like okay sure and then
we kissed and I was like wow this is wow
that's very whole who are you Anthony
Lee Jesus
the thing we dated that's [ __ ] it
just went like hey we like each other
just kissed right there she was cute too
yeah no no she was super cute she kissed
you you kissed her like who who went
closer first that's fast so was that
that was your first kiss yeah no I had a
kiss like before that you player
oh wow before that was kind of like a
dare okay that's cool that's cool but
still dude that's [ __ ] but then that
happened and I was like okay I guess I
have a girlfriend now and so we would
like hold hands do all the you know
coupling stuff like oh this is I didn't
know how to process it and I definitely
wasn't in love because I was like I
don't even know what that is so that
happened and then like a month later
um my friends would tell me like hey you
know your girlfriend cheated on you
she's with this other guy and I was like
oh really I'm like huh so that's so I
was like confused but I was like okay I
guess I shouldn't go out with her
anymore then but I wasn't like logic my
emotions weren't even like really like
if I was hurt or anything because I
didn't really understand it's too
yeah there was no attachment to her it
was more like oh I guess I'm in this
thing now oh I guess she cheated on me
so I guess I'm not with her anymore so I
was just like okay move on did you talk
to her about it like uh no I was just
like yeah I don't think I'm gonna be
with you anymore because this is wrong
or whatever and she's just like okay
yeah so practical it was literally like
that and I feel like my emotions weren't
even really attached to it at all it was
just like the actions of being in a like
you know a young couple relationship it
was a mock it was like a practice
because you're still thinking about am I
supposed to do this I'm still figuring
it out so instead of me feeling Xbox
well yeah my heart but then that
actually taught me a lot of how to be
aware of like
relationships in general it's like okay
what to do what not to do what's real
what's not real because to me that
wasn't even real like it was just like
it just happened it was like a fast
track trial run yeah yeah it was like a
demo do you count that as your first
girlfriend then yeah technically if you
if you go with it but in would I count
it as like a serious relationship not
really no so what about the next girl
the next girl yeah the next girl you got
in a relationship with like a serious
one or because I don't did you have more
of those yeah I did have a few of those
where it was just like I just liked
somebody and they just walk up to you
and they're like hey I heard you like me
can you
yeah pretty much but no dude Anthony
numbers a lot of that happened around
Middle School to high school and it was
just a lot of me just not knowing what
was going on and everybody was just
coming after your dick like quick no not
after my dig I didn't I didn't have sex
with any of these girls like during
these relationships because I didn't
know what that was like I I didn't know
like I was super like unaware of things
when I was that age so
yeah but that was that was going on yeah
it it was pretty wholesome up until like
high school where I was like getting
really horny I was like oh [ __ ] I really
want to do it now but I don't know how
to like Express that let's dive into
that a little bit well because the [ __ ]
out of each other no because like yeah
basically they're gonna start fighting
between them jeans because I lived with
my parents and the because I was dating
uh Asian girls their parents are super
conservative so there wasn't a lot of
like opportunities were they were they
mostly Vietnamese as well yeah mostly
and then oh and Korean too I did
yeah I mean that's just how it is right
but I feel like dating didn't really get
serious until after high school like
that was like the real relationships but
then but that's when you were a
superstar yeah that's true basically we
can't be talking Superstar dating
stories man you didn't have a normal
life anymore but ironically like my
first relationship after that happened
where I became a superstar it was all
all online like that one was pretty
interesting because like we never saw
face to face it was purely like text
relationships that's dope you could just
delete them instantly it was dope but
the thing that's not dope was I cheated
on her
whoa wait with another online yeah a
little chat room with like this is how I
lost my virginity actually oh you lost
your virginity In the Heat of infidelity
yeah because dude like I said the whole
time throughout middle school high
school my relationships weren't really
relationships because I didn't really
know what was going on right yeah you're
just kind of going through the motion
yeah and like I knew that this was wrong
because you know I hear about it all the
time but I didn't know why you know what
I mean and then until it happened and I
was like oh [ __ ] I feel really guilty I
feel this and that and I'm like I'm in
an online relationship that's not a real
relationship because like we don't
really see each other or anything I
don't even know this person like face or
anything and so I was like damn you
don't even know their face along with
you relationship uh just about a year
about you you didn't see no because like
I was because I was always busy they
lived in like Hawaii or something and
like I saw pictures of them and stuff
and this was before FaceTime before like
this was like iPhone two what What
attracted you to them or what kind of
chemistry was built uh I enjoyed
conversations uh we laugh a lot we talk
on the phone love caps lock hello
it felt like like Love Letter [ __ ] you
know what I mean but like a step above
that no I get you dude I get you how do
you know it wasn't like a dude though
prison well because I could hear their
voice oh you would talk to them still
yeah yeah vocally yeah but I didn't have
like video chat so I couldn't like but
that was in the back of my mind though
it was like is this person even real
like how do I know they're not like this
like super random person that does not
look like their photo and that's when
catfishing kind of came out you know and
I started kind of losing trust in that
relationship so I was like
dude I'm just gonna do whatever man I
don't care even though you were
committed I don't even count that one
that guy could have been a dude or
something exactly that guy he could have
been
into her voice no but I'm not saying
cheating is right or anything but I
wasn't in a very frustrated state where
I was like traveling all the time seeing
all these other cuter girls and then I
was just like man we're we're arguing
right now I'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ] so I
just went out and like did my thing yo
it was pretty bad because like I only
thought about myself the thing you did
like the chick was bad huh it was oh you
didn't have to say that
was PG-13 man it wasn't really it was a
really bad time in my life because a lot
of it I was very like not aware of
things I wasn't I was only thinking
about myself like it was a lot of
learning experience and that was the
time around like the tick tick Tour
times where like we were just constantly
traveling don't bring me into this man
you know yeah why'd you look at anything
like that because it was an exciting
trip let me tell you how legendary this
guy is you know what I'm saying no it
was around the time where things were my
life was just completely 180. so I was
like trying to process things while
trying to figure out myself and so that
happened and I said you know what I'm
gonna take a break from all of this [ __ ]
like no relationship whatever whatever
and I was single for like a year or so
and I was like I really need to just
focus on not being a [ __ ] dick like
to girls because dude that's really nice
because it sucks when I'm when you're
only thinking about yourself and you
just want things like oh I want a
girlfriend I want this I want that but
then you know [ __ ] happens and then you
you know you you were learning though I
like you know I I totally uh remember
that time in your life too and also just
the actual sincerity and the way that
you were perceiving and receiving things
you know and how you told the story
right now you were like learning as you
were going you didn't know these things
they had to exp you had to experience it
for it to happen you know so yeah to put
in perspective too uh during the tick
tick Tour times like you guys were
selling out auditoriums so it's like a
different type of high and feeling it
was yeah you got to get on top of the
world pretty much people are like
ripping your costumes off on the stage
and stuff like that you know yeah you
can't you're a wild boy he's a wild boy
know it was weird man it was a weird
time honestly today's video is brought
to you by Audible
so I've been doing my flights now back
and forth from the Hawaii and they're
about a good five hours and I'm like
what can I do for five hours well I
could sleep I could watch movies I could
do a lot of stuff but audible comes to a
lot of awesome stuff because I could
just rest my eyes and chill this is what
I've been checking out all of my content
here I got good thinking by David Robert
Grimes
this is brand new I still haven't
started this one but it's this kind of
cool like graph right and it's and it's
like it goes to like why flawed logic
can lead to like putting us all at risk
and then how critical thinking can save
the world so I've noticed like all over
the world you know some groups make
great decisions and then they solve
problems in a good way societal you know
all kinds of issues with the world but
there's also other destructive groups
and the only difference between the two
groups is the decisions that they make
how they see the world and how they
critically think or if they lack
critical thinking
so I was like this is really interesting
I want to check that out and I have a
bunch of other books that I just
listened to on the plane now and I like
it better than watching movies sometimes
because a lot of the stuff I get is like
school and learning and I don't go to
college no more and I really miss just
sitting there and listening to somebody
smart that can tell me about the world
yeah in addition to audiobooks Audible
has all kinds of audio entertainment we
got podcasts oh yeah they even got
Originals so they want to be your home
of Storytelling whether it's
storytelling about like fiction
non-fiction how to get better all that
stuff you can go to Audible and you can
get one book per month or one credit per
month and you can listen to either on a
car ride jogging or even on the airplane
it's the home of Storytelling you know
life is all about stories and I love
learning through stories let audible
help you discover new ways to laugh Be
Inspired or be entertained new members
can try it free for 30 days visit
audible.com off the Record or text off
the Record to 500-500 that's audible.com
off the Record or text off the Record to
500-500 to try audible free for 30 days
audible.com off the Record because it's
like you don't know you go from like
this kid who's like not cool at all at
school you're just like a nerd for
dancing and then all of a sudden you
blow up and then your life is just like
you know yeah so a lot I did a lot of
stupid [ __ ] I did like I got that's when
I got into like drugs partying a lot
drinking a lot and then it sounds like
fun [ __ ] where's the stupid stuff no the
thing is like I I fell into like a major
depression for like that's so stupid
yeah it was it was bad because you're
stupid because not only
to relate to the story yeah because not
only that there was like this whole
guilt that was just looming over me
constantly for like realizing all the
stupid [ __ ] I did in the in retrospect
like this person that you heard what's
stronger though guilt or ecstasy or more
ecstasy dude guilt on ecstasy that's
gotta be heavy yo dude remember when I
think so dude I want to tell that story
about me uh in Australia with the
birthday cake [ __ ] yeah yeah it was
during that time yeah maybe you were
thinking about a lot of other things and
that's why you snapped yeah probably but
dude that [ __ ] was wild but anyway yeah
that was my first relationship damn that
really led into a banger story bro
honestly that's dope oh that was great
like you gotta remember this is a tick
tick toy we keep on talking about it
from different uh times
this is like where like JK films was
that we were on the same tour together
we were there but this is the tick tick
tour like AKA it was like named after
the poor yodes and this is the second
the second one two so like their level
of just the way people were just
screaming waiting for them to come on
stage it was just another level honestly
there was there were chicks that were
just breaking into the hotel that we
were staying in you know I mean knocking
on these fools doors and stuff like that
and I was like why are they not I might
do this they're just like knocking on
these guys doors so I can only imagine
too like you're just in a world that's
way way like you said 180 from what
you're it's like everything is
constantly given to you and you're not
used to it imagine that like like one of
the venues we played at it was uh like
they said oh that Lady Gaga
we're like what the [ __ ]
and then like and then so The Whispers
we thought we thought like I mean we
were pretty big we had a pretty big
impact on the Asian American Community
but we were technically the openers you
know for probiotics to come out to close
the show yeah so we would do our show
and get like pretty good response and
then they did the [ __ ] like [ __ ]
lights out type [ __ ] and then
[Laughter]
and then they they come back out and
then they come back in and then only one
person knows only one person knows how
to do flips so you always watch out for
the shortest guy that flips
dude no it was crazy time I wouldn't
have thought that watching those shows
that you were [ __ ] thinking about
your online girlfriend I was so the
thing is Imagine like doing all this
tour [ __ ] and then dealing with like I
wouldn't say dealing with but like I was
in this weird relationship where I was
kind of like not sure what was happening
and then the I did I basically like
chose the worst decisions for both you
know like partied way too hard neglected
there's no blueprint for that [ __ ] yeah
I know for sure but that's how you learn
and how you become the person you are
today though yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna
get a little deeper into there in a
little bit more details with personal
stuff feel free to not have to share it
because it's okay no I'm your boss at
the show everything go
like after you know you uh ended up
cheating and losing your virginity and
stuff like what did you do after that
with the online relationship like how oh
I just [ __ ] lied and [ __ ] like I
straight up was like yeah I didn't do
that and then so and so was like well uh
my friend saw you here and I was like oh
[ __ ] okay and then I just kind of was
like dude I'm doing all the dumbest [ __ ]
right now that I knew was wrong digging
the whole home yeah I was digging the
hole and I was like dude why does my
mind keep just defaulting to that I
think it's because a big part of it was
one I never had to be in this situation
and the fear took over
and then I was like you know what
there's nothing I can do at this point
I've like gone as far as I can the wrong
way so now let's just close it out like
all right I'm done let it all go
apologize whatever and then move on what
do you say the fear take over is it like
some sort of self-sabotage or something
like the the fear of like uh I guess I
was more afraid of um hurting them even
though I'm hurting them worse you know
that yeah like why else would you lie
it's just to protect them from the truth
right but then for some reason like it
just kept going the wrong way yeah and I
was like because you're trying to avoid
the consequence of your actions over and
over and over again by doing that not
realizing that it's just making it worse
and worse and worse but you hear these
stories about why it's wrong but then I
never really knew why until that
happened and now I know because it's
like dude it just feels terrible like
it's the worst feeling yeah you know
but yeah thanks for sharing thank you
for sharing dude I'm fine now because
it's like
I can never go that direction anymore
because it was like the the deepest
deepest that I could possibly go as like
a person you know that was like over 10
years ago it was yeah yeah but then I'm
so happy that it happened because like
dude I'm like way on the other side now
they're just like gratitude gratitude
yeah you got your virginity back
congrats yeah
yeah so are you in a much happier place
now and you're just like wherever oh
yeah Everything feels way lighter like
there's nothing that's ever like latched
on to me because I just learned that
like okay this is obviously the right
decision and no matter how hard it is
sometimes you just gotta go with the the
hard way you know you don't be [ __ ]
freaky if you went on your Ayahuasca
trip and you just saw nothing but black
and then you just see typing and it says
you lied to me oh [ __ ] that's kind of
scary mine is wild that's creepy that
can be like you start hearing yeah and
then roll you [ __ ] yourself the shaman
goes what the [ __ ] what's the sound of
your performance in the background like
I hear it a lot stories about this [ __ ]
happening everyone hears the stories
about guys cheating and like this is the
worst thing you could do as a guy but
it's like when I see it from that
perspective
there's worse things you could do ah no
way
when I hear about it I can't I can't
help but think like
dude they're probably going through some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and nah not to be choosy
because or they're just like super
they're something in their brain is just
not there where they're just not the
only thing about themselves I think your
situation where you cheated is probably
more ideal than a lot of others yeah no
I think it is because you're not living
together you don't have a [ __ ] kid
you don't know what she looks like oh
strings attention that's a big thing
outside of three pictures yeah yeah you
only know what she looks like from three
pictures and you think that's a woman's
voice she's got gigabytes of footage of
you to download all over the interwebs
and you've got three photos for maybe
yeah it's a little more healable it is
but the thing is the act of me doing it
even if it wasn't a real situation it
still was it felt real oh yeah so but
that's but that's correct that's because
you're a good person you're totally
wrong you [ __ ] up and you should
totally feel how shitty that is but best
case scenario though but yeah like what
I said there's worse shitty yeah yeah
like Colleen keeps on alluding to
there's definitely way worse Anthony
what's worse
share with the class Colleen ladies
first well you said there's something no
I've already I've already given it back
to you you have to use a different
number Anthony
this guy's a deflector yo all right all
right guys let's focus so let me when I
first
you know got a girlfriend uh she came
with me and kissed me and I was sick
are you telling his story oh dude times
out dude videos no that's dope though I
think it's really cool to to express how
guilty you felt because that's how you
guys [ __ ] learn is you have to take
the [ __ ] bullet and be like I [ __ ]
up and then you don't do it next time
and then you allow that girl to go and
take it out of the next guy because it's
not your problem it's like everyone's
getting from experience like after I
learned from there like all my
relationships became way more real way
more wholesome and it just it just kept
getting better and better you know
you knew what you wanted after that yeah
I knew what not to do thank God it
didn't give birth to a pattern that's
the best thing or just give birth
thank God
the e-baby you know I got pranked one
time I got a phone call and it was this
guy that was just like hey uh I'm your
son and I was like no [ __ ] way he's
like you remember that Australian trip
when you were with so-and-so and I was
like no [ __ ] way did this guy sound
like a grown ass man it did because I
was I was like my heart started beating
I was like what the [ __ ] I have a son
and then but he's a [ __ ] like 19. and
then guess who it was it was [ __ ]
Dave Watanabe dude [ __ ] he was troll
he trolled the [ __ ] out of him so that's
both we had him as manager for both of
our crews yeah dude oh that guy yeah he
told the [ __ ] out of me dude he's funny
as [ __ ] yeah I was like [ __ ] Dave
dude got me because I believed it almost
yeah so that means you still do have a
son that's going on he just hadn't hit
you up yet no no no no
foreign